can you show me uh uh the junior's last
tweet
uh in regards to truth network coming
out i think he just posted this time for
some truth breaking uh this is this was
donald trump's first post on truth
social get ready your favorite president
will see you soon i mean he's always
humble it's it's such a unique quality
of his but get ready your favorite
president will see you soon
and that's out there with truth social
now truth social would be more of a
comparison competitor to you guys as
well as to twitter right would you say
true social so here is so
the way that i think you gotta look at
it isn't so much of here's one pie that
the alternative platforms have and
they're challenging each other and then
here's the big tech and the reason why
is facebook actually lost followers this
last quarter first time ever that
they've had a drop or they've lost
people twitter is the washington post
said i think megan mcgardell had a great
op-ed said their business model is
misery people just the the experience on
twitter have just been so negative and
nasty functionality is great twitter's a
well-oiled machine functionality wise
but just it's so negative a lot of
people are turned off from that
one thing to keep in mind is when
president trump was de-platformed and i
know this from my own market research
about 20 to 25 of his followers his
voters domestically from 20 2020 quit
social media
didn't necessarily delete their accounts
but they stopped using social media they
were frustrated they were turned off
they said
this is all rigged by 25
of his voters yes so he had you know
just under 75 million people about 20 to
25 percent somewhere right in between
there now it makes sense why he's never
on twitter
no exactly here's so here's what happens
when president trump announced in
october of this last year that he was
going to launch true social
over the next 10 days we had a 135
increase in signups versus the previous
10 days because here's what's happening
people are coming off the sidelines and
they're saying what's available what's
here we're here right now tour social is
not when president trump gets back in i
think it's going to get a lot more
people saying you know what maybe now's
the time this is the genesis this is the
spark point to go look at other
platforms that are not called big tech
so this isn't just a matter of us
fighting over some small pie twitter and
facebook are gonna lose a lot of people
to both true social and to us maybe even
some other platforms one trump gets in
and starts getting people jazzed up and
here's everything to keep in mind
facebook and twitter it's not like
they're taking their foot off the pedal
the facebook in particular launched
their quote-unquote global
misinformation and global
anti-misinformation effort which means
that anyone have an election in 2022
philippines colombia brazil france
they're going around and essentially
picking winners and losers doing their
warning labels um
doing the same nonsense that they did
with u.s elections so they're continuing
to drive people away on a daily basis
can you pull up the article from reuters
uh with trump about truth social sexual
terms opens on hundreds of testers out
of expected launch go go let me make it
a little bit bigger i want to read this
i haven't read this yet so reuters uh
details about foreign donald trump's new
social media app are trickling out as
about a 500
beta testers have begun using an early
version of truth social two sources told
reuters the testing of true social comes
a year after trump was banned from
facebook twitter and alphabet uh his new
media and technology venture trump
anderson has pledged to deliver an
engaging and censorship-free experience
on the app which uh chief executive
devin nunes has uh said will launch by
the end of march
uh truth remains shrouded in secrecy and
is regarded skepticism by some in tekken
media circles see the challenge with
this is the challenge with this is
he got a guy to go join him which is one
of the most powerful guys in tech
what is peter thiel doing resigning from
facebook board to go join him a
libertarian that wants to go join him he
must know something others don't a guy
like him is not going to go somewhere if
he doesn't think it's going to be a
winning formula and if he goes he can
probably make some phone calls to
recruit the best of the best engineers
because he's connected with everybody
and uh they don't come as smart as that
guy does that guy's a very he doesn't
want attention he's low-key he doesn't
want to get out there and talk he just
wants to deliver and so that guy teaming
up with him and i know you're saying
this is going to help our platform but i
the only way i think it would
is if trump was actually active on
getter because
i if i if a user one of the most
annoying thing about a user is the
following here's what users are getting
annoyed with
a user wakes up and is like look i used
to just have to check facebook now i
gotta check facebook then i gotta check
twitter then i gotta check youtube then
i gotta check instagram then i gotta
check linkedin then i gotta check tick
tock then i gotta now i gotta check get
out now i gotta do now i gotta it's so
many things for me to check off right so
don't you think this guy going out there
and doing what he does
it could possibly
uh because this is what a lot of people
are saying it could possibly
uh hurt some of the other startup
platforms out there like yours or maybe
even uh a rumble
so well that's the thing teal is a big
backer of rumble and so i know he is so
right and so one of the things also you
got to keep in mind
teal leaving
um
facebook or meadow whatever they're
calling themselves now
it's not as though he's leaving meta to
go do something trump it's he's leaving
i think you have to go and bifurcate the
two here's the reason why facebook's a
dying company uh i mean even zuckerberg
said that they're gonna lose 45 percent
of their audience 18 and under over the
next two years it just i mean kids don't
have facebook they have snapchat and
tick tock that's where they're going to
well instagram too and they're on
instagram and it's well and they said so
this is kind of where i'm getting to the
functionality instagram reels and this
is zuckerberg is most recent uh
quarterly investor report
instagram reels the short video format
drives about 60 percent of their
engagement that's anyone coming to any
of the broader instagram facebook
properties it's for instagram reels
that's what the whole so that's what we
launched because they're hyping those up
and they're basically that's working
because that's kind of like tick tock
reels go viral reels can take off so so
and we actually just launched yesterday
again the beta testing as we we start to
scale up vision which is our short video
format so that's why i said initially
we're competitors with twitter and
facebook now we're launching a product
that ultimately will go head to head
with tick tock instagram reels this is
even before we get to say the get or pay
as we go into the the crypto
payment platform we have the other thing
we have that's really popular right now
is live streaming
and just to give you a sense of the
scope when president trump had his rally
in arizona last month a million people
technically 996 thousand that's i'll
round up to a million a million people
watch president trump's rally on getter
over three different channels you had
right side uh you had newsmax and you
had a real america's voice those
combined so a million out of our four
and a half million were watching trump's
rally when he had his rally then in
conroe texas two weeks later yeah over
seven hundred thousand the live
streaming dynamic that we've added in
has been gangbusters not just here but
globally as well yeah that's one and
that's my concern because that's all
going to be on truth if he does that i
think it's a long play because even
truth
it's not it's not an easy thing to just
build something i would i would be
surprised i would be surprised i have
not seen from any of the beta testers
that they have live streaming in the in
the near future eventually they'll set
that but also you got to keep in mind at
least i'm kind of too young horn here we
have the short vision uh or the vision
the short video clip format which is
again that's where people are doing the
fun dances and all this stuff um that's
that's what all the younger folks are to
that's now i haven't seen that within
the beta testing for truth but then
where we're going ultimately keep in
mind
where truth wants to go and this is from
their their public deck they want to be
an entertainment and media creation
company they want to create content
that's if you take a look at the deck
that's where they want to go we're going
as more into the the financial services
and payment platform in crypto
aspect and so they're going to be areas
of commonality but here's everything too
when you talk about people opening up
the multiple apps multiple social media
platforms right now people are looking
and saying yes you have your twitter
your facebook your others i'm not so
sure that as these new platforms ours
true social and others start to pop up
the people and say you know what i have
these
platforms i like i don't need to go to
twitter anymore i don't need to go to
facebook anymore i'll open up maybe
truth maybe we'll open up getter
maybe someone will open up parlor or
rumble whatever the case those are the
ones i'm doing i don't need to worry
about the old big tech platforms who are
censoring me politically yeah you know i
told this to chris if you remember when
we were talking i said i said the the
the what's going to help today is you
got to get something on your show
on your platform that i can only get on
your platform right like what you were
talking about with earlier conversation
we're having with you being a pundit at
a couple different places and one of the
places you you were expressing what the
what the uh terms and conditions was is
for example
why why did i go to spotify i've never
downloaded spotify until rogan went on
spotify i've never downloaded spotify
ever in my life until rogan went there
then i said i'm gonna go to spotify
right you know bill maher to me right
now is one of the most valuable voices
out there because believe it or not i
think he is a voice of reason right you
got the right it's also a reflection of
how off track uh the americans totally i
love what he said you know you always
say he says i i didn't change you
changed i've been the same for the last
30 years i'm still the same old
smoking happy liberal whatever whatever
so so i think he's very necessary i
think
uh our russell brand is very necessary i
think jon stewart jon stewart oh my gosh
if he came out of retirement whoever was
able to pick him up that guy his good
friend hassan minaj
is sound
one of the highly requested guys to be
on the podcast guys want to have a
seminar funny guy yeah so
these guys are necessary i think like
you know you know it's just i think the
battle is very similar to hulu netflix
hbo showtime like
when sasha baron cohen had his show on
showtime i'm like give me a damn break i
got to go order yeah you got a showtime
app right when you know
what's his name uh shia labeouf one of
my favorite actors his story that he
made that movie about the story of his
father honey boy something like that it
was only on amazon i had to go get
amazon's app on my
tv to see it right but house of cards is
why i joined netflix first if there
wasn't a house of cards i would have
never downloaded netflix right so it got
me in through house of cards so all i'm
saying is you i think
this guy's not a guy that's going to be
a lightweight to go out there and do
what he's doing trump because he's
preparing his campaign for 2024 and you
know more than i know he's running it's
not like he ain't going to run i spent
three hours with him yesterday afternoon
yeah so i wouldn't visit him at
mar-a-lago oh i'm gonna go see him this
afternoon so that's great i'll text you
guys
yeah so so he's kidding by the way he's
not he's not a guy that's a very but
although he had his best podcast a
couple days ago but he said people were
blown away by it but but but the reason
why i say this reasonable people out
there i think i think you need someone
to be a face
that i can only get
on
getter and you got to spend some money
to get something like that so i think so
to that point i think they're they're
yes you're exactly right i may be wrong
i'm just speculating no you're you're
right on a big party that's pat pitching
you to haste uh give us some money we'll
head out no no no no not at all i'm not
asking about us i'm not at all
here's the thing when we bring on the
content creators and we're able to and
again we'll undercut the competition and
come in they're allowing to keep that
much that much more money uh literally
being you know 50 to 100 percent less
than what anyone else has charged them
to take take the rip
off of it that's going to be a driver
for a lot of content creators we are
pursuing some additional partnership
deals to have some of that that creative
but also too
to your point just about people having
to bounce around to different platforms
with ours if you have the micro blogging
if you have the short video essentially
the tick tock the instagram reels type
you have the live streaming then you
also have this crypto and the payment
platform aspect that then makes it the
all-in-one free speech platforms so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you